foreign
Federal appeals court has temporarily
blocked President Biden's student loan
forgiveness plan halting any debt from
being erased but the administration is
encouraging people to continue
submitting their applications the Friday
evening ruling comes less than a week
since the application portal went live
already nearly 22 million people more
than half of qualifying buyers have
signed up the administration could have
begun processing applications and
changing loan balances beginning Sunday
the order does not reverse the trial
Court's dismissal of the case or suggest
that the case has Merit the White House
Press Secretary said in a statement the
block was issued by the U.S eighth
Circuit Court of Appeals which is
considering a motion from Six
republican-led States to stop the
forgiveness program it's one of several
lawsuits that have aimed to challenge
the program
Six States Arkansas Missouri Nebraska
Iowa Kansas and South Carolina filed a
lawsuit arguing the federal relief
program would hurt state-based loan
companies that manage some of the loans
themselves earlier this week a federal
judge dismissed the case saying it as no
standing the group then appealed and
that's the federal appeals court to
place a temporary hold on the program
while the appeals court reviews the case
one of two things can happen in the
upcoming days either the court can issue
an injunction and the pause will last
longer or can dismiss the case the
program can carry on the federal appeals
court is expected to announce a ruling
as early as next week
oh man I've been saying for a while
buckle up y'all this is going to get
interesting and it is interesting right
now
there's a lot of feelings a lot of
emotions out there I mean 22 million
people have already applied and are
counting on it but at the same time
there's this block and the pause is
coming to an end January 1st so people
are really wondering what's going to
happen I would be very curious to know
your thoughts Dave
well it's not a conspiracy theory it's
just a political chessboard
playing with people's real lives
people's lives are always on the end of
the political chess board but the
political chess board is this
I told you
uh last spring in March to expect
President Biden to issue some kind of
student loan forgiveness just in time
for the midterms yep
to prop his little political butt up
because he's a failed president by any
standards you have to be extremely
left-wing to think that weekend that
Bernie is working up there okay it's you
just got to be off your rocker now it's
gotten out the cat's out of the bag it's
a mess and uh the you know most polls
are showing us that these midterms are
going to be a bloodbath but aside from
that I'm not a political analyst but if
I were doing politics if I were in
Biden's shoes I would have done exactly
what he's doing I think it's brilliant
uh one of the few brilliant things he's
actually done but um brilliant
absolutely brilliant to issue a student
loan forgiveness program knowing that
it's going to be challenged knowing that
there's some question of the
constitutionality that the president has
the power to do this without Congress
approving a half a trillion dollar
s
forgiveness program without congress's
approval an unprecedented
for a president to be able to pull this
off uh
many scholars say unconstitutional but
I've yet to see a constitutional
challenge come through this is not a
constitutional challenge it's a
challenge on the other basis so uh what
am I not a legal scholar obviously so
um you know but from a political
chessboard standpoint he issued it and
here's here's what's going to happen
either it was going to just Sail on
through
and he gets the credit for having the
political cred for having forgiven
people's loans and buys their votes
which is his game plan or the amino
Republicans stop him and these are
Republican Governors at these states
these are Republican states that have
gone against him and so if it gets
blocked and people don't get the
Forgiveness he's in a perfect seat to
blame the Republicans see I tried to
help you people but the Republicans hate
The Working Man and that's all he's you
know he set this up so perfectly in the
timing I mean now this circuit court has
to rule on it the week before the
midterm elections
I mean the week of midterm elections
like maybe you know it's uh two weeks
from today
November 8th yeah so uh as we're doing
this show live at this moment that's
that's the situation so as a political
chess board his timing was perfect and
his play was perfect because the
Republicans had no upside to this they
come off looking like the old meanie
that doesn't want their student loans
forgiven or they let this slide through
and we have another half a trillion
dollars hit the books because you can't
forgive loans you have to pay them off
the money comes from somewhere these
banks have to get their money they're
going to get their money it means the
federal government is paying off the
loans
that's then paying off the ten thousand
dollars worth of loans so that means
national debt is going up again by
another half a trillion dollars in an
inflationary economy we continue to suck
cash out of the money supply and uh so
it's it's a political like you said
buckle up it's a political ride now you
can disagree with my uh political
ascertainment or whatever you want but
you got to admit whether you love Biden
or whether you don't in terms of
political chess board it was it was
brilliantly played yeah and his timing
is perfect and I also said expect
whatever he does to look like it's a big
deal but it won't be a big deal I said
that in March you said it I remember it
and guess what it's not a big day it's a
big deal because of the total amount of
money but to an individual that has 90
000 in student loan debt for giving ten
thousand dollars in student loan debt
does not fix your life
on the contrary it makes you want to sit
on your butt again and wait on
Washington to forgive the rest of it
that's what you're trying to do
meanwhile the bozos up there keep making
these loans that are so evil that we
must forgive them and yet we keep making
them that's intellectually dishonest as
it can be
so how do you keep a student loan
program in place that's harming the
American public so much so that it must
be forgiven and keep making the loans
that's completely intellectually
dishonest and that tells you that this
is politics
odd infant item and see here's the they
still have not answered the questions
okay you can file an application
and this idea that they're going to
forgive the loans by Sunday is
absolutely bull crap because the at the
the loan forgiveness program announced
by the White House says that you have to
make less than 125 thousand dollars
what year
last year
well that's a good question and they're
not even requiring additional how are
you how are they proving
like I I promise I promise I didn't make
more than 125 000. you don't have to
turn in tax returns
you don't I mean how are you proving
your income
they're taking your word for it dang I
don't think so so I think there's some
other stuff this is uh this is not the
last we've heard from this it's going to
continue on it is a um
it's um it's a bit of a mesh it's a mess
but what would you tell all the people
who in their minds this is already a
done deal who who are counting on this
and and I mean they don't they don't see
any chance that this could not happen
well these would be these people would
fall into two categories naive people
that are young
and unbelievably naive people that are
old
because if you're young I I can
appreciate that you've not been screwed
by your government yet and so this is
your first time on this trip when you're
old like me you've been like they've
promised me stuff before you know and so
far none of the success in old Dave
Ramsey's life has come as a result of
anything Washington has done as a matter
of fact it's been all in spite of
everything Washington has done and
that's both freaking parties so uh never
Santa Claus don't live in DC I know the
old guy he lives in the North Pole and
he ain't there and so you're waiting on
the government to fix your life darling
your life's gonna suck
when the government says we're here to
help that's like saying hey the DMV line
is short you know I mean come on really
seriously dumber than crud so yeah
please it just means you're naive you're
sweet and I that's nice of you and and
you know I don't mind actually if your
ten thousand dollars is Forgiven it's
not the end of the world uh I hate that
it's all a political thing and it's
obvious political chessboard work it's
obvious it's no question well and I
think it's a good it's a good wake-up
call for people who are counting on this
forgiveness to still think about
controlling the controllables and think
about your budget what you control if
these payments happen again in January
forgiveness doesn't go through how are
you going to pay off your loans think
about that now don't wait till the last
minute don't wait till it's due start
thinking about that now
there's also the moral aspect like hey
you borrowed the money
and now a guy who's a welder
he owes the money
because it got moved over he didn't have
student loans
and he got moved over to the national
debt and we all owe that as people
this is just immoral this is the Ramsay
show